clarissa Shen welcome to intersect 2018
mic on there we go hello my name is
Clarissa Shen I'm the chief operating
officer here at Udacity and your MC for
today welcome to our special guests
welcome to our partners and welcome
especially to all of you our students we
chose the theme of lifelong learning
today at intersect to recognize support
honor and celebrate both the practical
and the revolutionary the act of
lifelong learning rejects complacency
it rejects what is it looks towards the
future horizon at the same time it
embraces the practical and you all know
this you have to work hard you have to
plan ahead for both yourself and your
family to make time for your learning
for your careers for your families
you are the makers and doers of today
ultimately we chose the theme of
lifelong learning for you by your
dynamic and ongoing commitment to the
act of lifelong learning you represent
the brightest hopes for tomorrow our
goal is that you leave today energized
to take the next steps in your career to
start your next big thing and to connect
with new friends from around the world
in the same community before we get
started though I wanted to send a shout
out to the many international students
viewing this through livestream please
join me camera over there and wave hello
to all of them hello Berlin hello Munich
London Cairo South Paulo and to some of
our students who are staying up way too
late and Asia hello to you as well thank
you all for coming to intersect 2018 a
few notes of housekeeping before we get
started please keep your
cell phones on silent no please don't
turn them off I see some people reaching
for them please don't turn them off we
want you to be social we want you to
post pictures selfies live Instagram to
your heart's content and please share
them using these handles today please
introduce yourself to your neighbors can
turn to each other
introduce yourself and don't be shy we
challenge you to make 5 new connections
by the end of today and last but not
least please be on time for your
sessions as we have a fully packed
schedule on that note please join me in
welcoming to the stage
Udacity CEO Michele Mackay Gianni
[Music]
my family is from a city called
Hyderabad in Pakistan not long not long
ago it was part of India my grandfather
had a small factory downstairs from
where they lived they made hen hand sewn
notebooks made with thread like the one
you see in this picture they had nine
children including my mom it was a
simple life it was a good life until
tragedy struck in 1947 India broke away
from British rule and Hindus and Muslims
decided to split apart there was famine
and there was blood in the streets
two million people died after my uncle
was almost killed outside their home my
grandparents knew they had to run for
their lives they left behind everything
everything they along with ten million
other people headed south to India
people walked for miles that piled into
overcrowded trains and boats they picked
up little ones and the elderly and put
them on their backs it was a treacherous
journey my grandparents made it to
Mumbai
about 800 miles on the map 4000 miles by
car they settled into a one-room 200
square foot ground-floor apartment my
grandparents there now nine children as
well as a handful of relatives all
stayed there my grandfather may had had
no money but was committed to rebuilding
with the winds of change had brought
them he started sewing notebooks again
one by one Baba my mom and every member
of the family made and sold books at the
market bit by bit
he saved enough money to hire some help
and eventually he rebuilt a small
factory years later he handed it down to
one of his sons my uncle who then
continued to grow the business and
modernize it along the way he ultimately
employed more than 150 people now my
grandparents didn't ask for this change
but they did what they had to do to
survive and eventually thrive they made
it possible for generations for our
family to earn a quality education
improve their lives and my mom became a
doctor as did her sister and her brother
and today I get to live in Silicon
Valley and work at a company that is
helping people transform their lives
through education I know that this
conference is being live-streamed all
around the world including places where
people are escaping violence struggling
with the day-to-day in refugee camps or
rebuilding after one disaster of one
kind or another for those of you I hope
that my grandfather story gives you hope
a reminder that it's instead of giving
up you can keep moving forward you can
thrive for everyone else listening or
watching I hope this story reminds you
that whatever change is happening around
you you have inside of you the strength
you need to transform your life as well
as the lives of those around you
I hope the work we are doing here at
Udacity will be part of that positive
transformation we are a global community
and our ever-growing alumni network
inspires us every day since we
introduced nano degrees in late 2014
more than 30,000 of you have around the
world have graduated from Udacity in
fields of mobile and web development
artificial intelligence digital business
and autonomous systems our graduates
have landed jobs at amazing companies
from Atlassian to Zulu Li literally a to
Z we work with more than 120 amazing
companies including Amazon BMW Google
IBM mercedes-benz lyft and NVIDIA the
skills we teach are in demand in every
industry from agriculture manufacturing
and finance to healthcare entertainment
and retail all over the world Fatima
Fatima was born in Kuwait when Desert
Storm began her family fled to Iraq she
studied to become a pharmacist at
Baghdad University but in 2013 her
family was yet again displaced by war
isis infiltrated the city in iraq where
she lived and again her family had to
flee to safety after all the destruction
she witnessed firsthand she swore that
someday she would find a career that
helped other people in 2016 Fatima had
an amazing year she signed up for a
recoded Udacity boot camp she learned
Android joined an incubator and raised
seed capital for a brand new startup
called tech teens a school that teaches
children and teenagers how to code what
a year change is happening all the time
whether we like it or not and believe it
or not it's happening faster than it
used to pcs were invented just about 40
years ago and now we have super
computers in our pockets we hold more
computational power in these phones than
it was required to put a man on the moon
in 1969 in 2020 more than six billion
smartphones will be around the world how
did this all happen so fast each
generation of tech leverages the
technology of the generation before and
uses that technology as a tool to create
the next level of innovation it's a
never-ending cycle that
on itself futurist reycarts while said
our rate of progress doubles every
decade he said we won't experience a
hundred year progress in this century
but 20,000 years of progress it's that
exponential rate of change that made it
possible for our very own Sebastian
throng along with a team of aerospace
engineers machine learning experts
robotics geniuses and computer
scientists to introduce just a few weeks
ago the world's very first all-electric
cell flying vertical takeoff and landing
air taxi named Korra
pretty cool right our flying card nano
degree program kicked off last month
with partner and with partners like
Kitty Hawk and lilium gearing up to hire
our grads flying cars are served solving
a couple of very serious problems that
affect people living in both urban as
well as rural communities the lack of
infrastructure and traffic a billion
people in the world 1/7 of the world's
population don't have access to all
season roads they are cut off from
critical resources like hospitals food
and water let alone the ability to
conduct commerce in sub-saharan Africa
85 85 percent of the roads are
inaccessible during the wet season in
order to build roads equivalent ooh the
United States it would take over 23
years and over four trillion dollars one
solution skip it skip all that expense
and get the people the the access they
need faster by going to the air in much
the same way as mobile phones helped
billions leapfrog landlines autonomous
flight has the potential to help leap
people leapfrog over their lack of roads
and highways people living in cities
face different problems fast growing
populations and economies are literally
straining against roadways and mass
transit systems urban density has led to
horrible traffic in places like Bangkok
Moscow and Jakarta I've been you've seen
it it's awful it's strangling business
in Beijing traffic jams cost the city
more than 11 billion dollars per year in
fact in the world's worst traffic city
Mexico City 21 million people struggled
through brutal day long commutes and
they also struggled to breathe Mexico
said he had only 26 days of acceptable
quality and the first half of 2016
audacity grads are working to solve some
of these problems though mega Maheshwara
dreamed of engineering cars of the
future
she started embedded systems at
University in Singapore and electronics
and telecom in India she got herself one
step closer to her dream by pursuing a
nano degree from Udacity in self-driving
cars today
she's an autonomous driving engineer at
Volvo and a member of the self-driving
team at women women who code mega is one
of 10,000 students who have enrolled in
Udacity self-driving car program 42,000
students have applied and more than 400
students graduated late last year
thousands more will graduate this year
already our students have gotten jobs at
amazing companies like BMW Nvidia
Lockheed Bosh and lyft and others by
2025 this market is expected to be 42
billion dollars if you'd like to
experience the liberty of the future for
yourself waiting outside in our parking
lot is Carla the Udacity self-driving
student test car and she's available for
ride alongs and selfies also it's hard
to design transportation systems of the
future when you're living in a city that
was designed 75 years ago back then
cities were less dense we didn't have
autonomous drones cars taxis or flying
cars in addition to stoplights and
signals on the ground we need to think
about how will Corral traffic in the
skies we need to think at a systems
level to coordinate entire fleets of
moving vehicles on the ground in the sky
operating on multiple planes Udacity is
answer today we are introducing an
entirely new learning experience a
large-scale virtual world called Udacity
universe this online simulation
environment will be available this
summer starting with all of our self
driving car and flying car nandri
students teams will be able to develop
software and tools to control autonomous
vehicles on the ground and in the air
learning to solve complex transportation
problems let's take a look Udacity
universe is a massive shared simulation
environment
that allows students to tackle problems
at scale collaboratively together when
we're talking about a massive virtual
world it means that virtually anything
is possible
the flying car students will control
aerial vehicles the self-driving car
students will control self-driving cars
five years from now many of the
transportation actions that we require
will be performed by an autonomous
vehicle but that's flying or it's on the
ground or students will be able to build
large scalable systems and try them out
experience what works what doesn't
you will learn not just how to control
individual vehicles but actually many
vehicles all performing different tasks
and doing it in an efficient
goal-directed way help us with the
future with udacity universe and sign up
for the self-driving car program or
flying car program now
[Music]
[Applause]
you get to play video games while you
study we are partnering with a number of
future binding organizations to make
Udacity universe possible including
Unity Technologies creators of unity the
real-time development platform zipline a
robotics maker that uses drones to
deliver emergency medical supplies and
world a 3d maps an indoor visualization
platform meet them all today in the
nanodegree lounge change is a fact of
life but sometimes it's not a change we
want by 2030 as much as one third of the
work we do today could be displaced by
automation while some use statistics
like this as a cause for alarm we see
opportunity machine learning and
artificial intelligence make us smarter
we can understand more and make better
decisions the kind of decisions that
lead to 20,000 years of progress in the
next hundred years smart and ethical
applications of AI will transform the
world Udacity is educating more AI
engineers than anyone else and we're
about to double down today we are
introducing the school of AI the school
of AI will include seven nano degree
programs our existing machine learning
and deep learning foundations program an
updated AI program focused on AI
essentials top our very own Sebastian
run and Peter Norvig and four new nano
degree programs AI programming with
Python computer vision natural language
processing and deep reinforcement
learning all of these programs map to
jobs in the fast changing world of
artificial intelligence what can you do
with AI for starters you could be an AI
perception engineer in Google research
like Aaron Iglesias or you could also
deploy AI to deliver energy from wind
turbines in Brazil like Robson Mattos at
Kubica robots can run faster lift more
weight and even fly they never
complained they don't get tired and they
don't feel pain contrary to the way
they're often portrayed in sci-fi movies
robots save lives co bots are safely
working alongside people in factories
sparing line workers from injury and
serious harm zip lines flying robots are
delivering medical supplies all across
Rwanda
and robots are also performing surgery
more accurately and less invasively than
we ever have before to help students
push robotic innovation forward last
year at intersect we launched our
robotics nano degree program but that
wasn't enough we know how important it
is to test your code by deploying it on
real hardware and this spring all of our
robot nano degree students will have
access to the brand-new cuca Udacity
robot Learning Lab from now on all
Udacity robotics students will be able
to run remotely their code on real
industrial robots in a robotics lab at
the Karlsruhe Institute of Technology no
other online robotics course can offer
this kind of real-world experience let's
take a look automation with robotics is
becoming a differentiator in the
manufacturing industry the skills you
need to know for a career in this
robotics field are changing at the
fastest rate in history at Udacity our
goal is to empower you with the
real-world relevant skills that make you
successful at your job today
and prepare you for the jobs of tomorrow
our self driving car nano degree program
allowed students the exclusive
opportunity to put their code on a real
self-driving car now our robotic
students will have the opportunity to
control real cuca ira robots located in
germany i am a professor of computer
science at cultural institute of
technology in germany students will have
the opportunity to program these robots
the experience with working with
physical robots is very different from
working with robots and simulation this
is something very unique you cannot find
this in any other online program and
even
many universities it's very rare to get
access to real top-notch hardware join
Udacity the robotics software engineer
nano degree program to learn the latest
in robotics software technology and gain
access to this exciting opportunity we
look forward to seeing you in the
classroom alright you can check it out
today in our Navy lounge and see your
code in action and thank you again to
KUKA and Kait for making this possible
in Alice in Wonderland there's a scene
in which the Queen of Hearts is talking
to Alice she says my dear here we must
run as fast as we can just to stay in
place and if you wish to go anywhere you
must run twice as fast as that the same
is true for all of us personally not too
long ago after we graduated from
university many of us expected to work
for 30 years at the same company until
we got a gold watch today the average
person will have will have 10 different
jobs by the time they're 40 and if
you're a millennial it might be 15
change is the new constant but you're
one of those people who sees around
corners you don't let change happen to
you
you happen to it and people like you are
exactly the type of people that make
Udacity what it is an agency of change
we know that going to school is hard
particular when you have a job and can't
afford to take time off it's even harder
if you're a family Udacity is working
hard to improve access to education that
matters
JP Miller was drifting from job to job
the year he turned 30 he found out his
wife was pregnant change was happening
to JP and it was happening fast
he considered going to Community College
but that was expensive and also far from
home what JP didn't give up he completed
the front-end web developer nano degree
in just eight months and now he owns his
own web design agency and he also
teaches web development to inner-city
youth yet asking our partners off on
multiple options for folks who can't
afford tuition today we have more than 8
million people enrolled in hundreds of
free courses and we also offer
our ships as well in fact so far 180,000
scholarships have been funded by
industry partners from great companies
such as Google lyft AT&T Bertelsmann as
well as governments and NGOs partners as
well maybe you have a non-traditional
background or maybe your current job
isn't relevant and all this sounds like
a faraway dream maybe like Abdullah wasa
Osman you have to completely start over
and you aren't even sure where to begin
Abdullah was originally from Eritrea
when he arrived in Germany as a refugee
in 2015 he had never seen a computer he
received a Udacity Vienna degree
scholarship and on the ground the
support from cord code.org for the next
12 months
Abdullah so I went to German class
during the day and spent evenings and
weekends learning how to code in January
he graduated from the front-end web
developer nano degree and got his first
internship at dwell in Germany Udacity
gives you a competitive advantage
because we custom build our nano degrees
with companies that innovate and create
opportunities for growth today we are
launching a WeChat nanodegree together
with 10 cent in China students can
register today and start learning in
April to gain the skills to build mini
programs on WeChat this is an
opportunity to reach a massive audience
WeChat counts more than 1 billion
monthly active users and in addition
$0.10 will provide 1 million remin be
and scholarships for students in China
increasing access to technology amazing
major driving force at Udacity
unfortunately the industry doesn't look
like the rest of the world according to
the US census in 2045 this is what
America will look like people who use
the products made it so Silicon Valley
are not the same as the people who are
making them in 2015 black and Hispanic
people represented only 7% at top valley
companies and women comprise only 25% of
computing roles today tech companies
want to do better though leadership from
Google lift box
Warby Parker Etsy and others have made
recruiting and supporting a more
workforce major priority whether you
want to launch a new career expand
opportunities for you or are starting a
family or building new skills in your
current field our programs are designed
to be more accessible for more people
for example three years ago
Ryan weight was stocking shelves at a
big-box store he understands a
scholarship for a front-end web
developer nanodegree through an
organization called year up and after
graduation he landed a position as a
data analyst at NASA today Ryan is a
senior web developer for the US
Department of Labor
Hideko is a working mom with two small
children living in Hungary she already
had a master's degree in language and
literature but want to expand her
opportunities for herself and for her
family she earned a scholarship from
Google for Android basics Anna dqo is
now a graphic designer and an Android
developer and she even created her own
app called green feet wood measures your
carbon footprint and then there's a mojo
mojo Miller was already on a technology
leadership path she had already earned a
PhD from University of California at
Berkeley and she's been working for a
decade in computational intelligence
emoji then signed up for a machine
learning nano degree at Udacity and
today she's a senior machine learning
data scientist at github and a member of
the World Economic Forum expert network
in AI amazing work there's an enormous
gap between the size of the opportunity
and the amount of people who are
actually qualified to seize it
in fact by 2020 McKinsey estimates a
shortfall of over 40 million people in
high-skilled jobs that's a tremendous
opportunity for all of you in this room
underneath your chair is a book similar
to the ones my grandfather used to make
in India please take it out
now take a moment to think about what
you would do if nothing stood in your
way something you want to do for your
family your community for yourself
something you once thought you were
incapable of doing something you once
thought was beyond you now write down
come on
I can tell you from experience that the
surest way for you reach this goal that
you just wrote down is through focused
intentional lifelong learning
it will require hard work it will
require sacrifice and the right
opportunities look around at all the
other faces in this room as well you'll
see you're not alone in your quest at
Udacity we work for you and we are
humble to serve you every day we applaud
your bravery your determination and your
grit and we know we're you were going to
reach your goals and transform your life
and the lives of those around you thanks
[Applause]